Aei,
northern은
kurvustum
We have a few cans of food and a rabbit. For what? 10, 12 people?
When I was in the Navy.
I do not wish to hear about what you got up to in the Navy, Mr. Pearson.
We were stranded at sea for 50 days.
And you unfortunately survived.
When we ran away from Blackwater, I wasn't able to get supplies in.
Well, when government agents are hunting you down, sometimes shopping trips need to be cut short.
We'll survive. We always have.
If needs be, we can eat you. You're the fattest.
I sent Lenny and Bill hunting and they found nothing.
Lenny's more into book learning than hunting. Bill's a fool.
Unless those mountains are full of game that want to read, ain't no wonder they found enough of this.
We'll go find something. Come on, Arthur.
Wait a second. Hold on.
Here. You're gonna need something to eat out there.
Assorted salted offal. Starving will be preferable.
Come on, let's go.
You can't go hunting. Look at your hand.
I can't stay here listening to you two.
Look, if this game and those hills, I'll find it. And you can kill it.
You need to rest, Charles.
You think this is rest?
Come along.
I'll take you to the forest.
Here. You take this. I can't use it and you'll have to.
You're joking.
Use a gun and we'll scare off every animal for miles around.
You're never too old to learn. I imagine.
All right. Let's head out.
How's this?
Mean?
This isn't safe.
現在 você está pagando?
O diedro até aqui.
Está bem bom.
Comude.
É Gin.
You reckon we're gonna find something to kill that ain't an old driskel?
There's meat up here for sure.
Pearson doesn't know what he's talking about.
Now the weather's eased off a bit, they'll be needing to feed.
We'll head up this way, find some higher ground.
Been a wild few days, all right.
That ride north from Blackwater, getting stuck in this storm, bringing John back in.
You've had a lot put on you.
I wish I could have done more.
I didn't mean it like that, just a lot to think back on.
I still don't really know what happened on that boat.
Me neither.
Well, Javier told me a bit, but it sure weren't good.
People don't come for the bait.
Can you find anything useful for him to trek up amongst?
I certainly can.
What can I do?
It's rare to hear that, though.
All we need is a last-minute look.
We can teach you how to get up above the sun at one turn, particularly pure luck.
Anecdotesым, there's no time to lose.
An ennuião.
You'll only get better knowledge there sometimes.
Yeah, I dunno.
And what?
Nothing?
Nothing.
Hey, stop here a second. I see something.
Easy.
There's deer been here. Recently.
How can you tell?
How can you not?
Let's walk it from here.
You're gonna need the bow. Don't leave it on your horse. A gun will scare everything around.
Keep down. Move quietly and slowly.
You see the tracks?
I think so. Maybe not.
Focus.
It's easier in the snow, but once you get your eye in, you'll be able to track them nearly as well in grass and woods.
Yes, next to a tree, you'll see them running.
Is it upstairs?
This must be a view of the place, at least.
Yes, it is.
This is it.
We'll need to get over to the far end and then go back.
It appears this trail leads all the way to the other's.
And then we do, so that leaves us to find another núcleoad.
Here's his trail.
Rails.
Good tension on the string before releasing. Just don't overdo it.
Now, Arthur.
Good shot. Now let's try for another.
Good shot.
Okay. I'll go grab the other one.
What are you doing? Let's get out of here.
NICE WORK ARTHUR
SHOULD BE ENOUGH MEAT HERE TO KEEP US ALL FED FOR A FEW DAYS
YOU FOUND THEM
I KNEW YOU'D BE OKAY WITH THAT BOW
IT'S EASIER WHEN THEY AIN'T SHOOTING BACK
WE'VE SEEN ENOUGH OF THAT
CENTERING HOW THINGS WERE LOOKING A COUPLE OF DAYS BACK
MAYBE OUR LUCK IS FINALLY ON THE TURN
SEEMS TO ME WE SHOULD BE PUTTING OUR EFFORT INTO GETTING OFF THIS MOUNTAIN NOW
SOON?
PEOPLE ARE STILL WAKE AND YOU'VE SEEN HOW SNOWED IN THOSE WAGONS ARE
THEY AIN'T GOING NOWHERE UNTIL WE GET SOME MORE THAW
YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT
AND EVEN IF WE DO GET OFF HERE
WHAT THAT?
WE STILL HAVE A BIG PRICE ON OUR HEADS
THIS IS A BIG COUNTRY
WE'LL FIND SOMEWHERE TO LIE LOW
DUTCH AND JOSE WILL HAVE A PLAN
YOU NOTICE HOW PEARSON'S HAD A BOTTLE IN HIS HAND EVER SINCE WE FLAT BLACKWATER?
WE GIVE THE CAMP COOK FIVE MINUTES TO GRAB THE ESSENTIALS AND GO
AND HE DOESN'T EVEN BRING A CRUMB OF FOOD
GOOD THOUGH WE CAUGHT MORE THAN ONE
A LOT OF MOUTHS TO FEED
AND THAT GIRL FROM THE RANCH NOW TOO
BUT NOT SURE IF SHE'LL BE EATING MUCH
SHE HAS A WILD LOOKING MOUTH
AND A LITTLE BIT OF A DARK EYE
YOU WOULD TOO
SHE LOST HER HUSBAND, HER HOME, EVERYTHING SHE HAD
SO WHAT DO WE DO WITH HER?
ONCE WE GET OUT OF HERE AND WE'RE BACK ON OUR FEET WE'LL SEE
SHE MIGHT HAVE FAMILY SOMEWHERE
SO IT WAS O'DRISCALS YOU RAN INTO THERE?
YEAH, LAST THING WE WAS EXPECTING
WHAT IS IT WITH THE O'DRISCALS?
YOU AIN'T DEALT WITH THEM?
I SUPPOSE, WE AIN'T RUN INTO THEM MUCH THOUGH
THE LAST SIX MONTHS
I GUESS BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN OVER THIS WAY
AH, I'VE HEARD A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THEM
WELL, WE'VE BEEN SCRAPPING OVER SCORES WITH THEM FOR YEARS
BIG GANG, NASTY SONS OF BITCHES
THEIR LEADER, COLEM, AND DUTCH GO WAY BACK
AND NOT IN A GOOD WAY
A PROPER BLOOD FUEL
SO I HEARD
uggle to get a NAT TEST
braid
S constructor
he really
Miami
can't
It's alright, boy.
You ain't ever talked that much, you and me.
How long you been with us now? Five, six months?
Something like that.
Bet you didn't expect this.
What?
Any of this.
Blackwater mess.
Being up here.
Ah, sooner or later a job's gonna go wrong. Nature of life.
I just thought you might have moved on by now.
You want me to move on?
No. No, not at all. I just...
I know you can run it alone, no problem.
I did that for a long time.
I'm done with it.
Always wondering if someone's gonna kill you in your sleep.
I still wonder that most nights.
I reckon you're okay.
Hey, this suits me.
Sure, I could fall in with another gang, but Dutch...
You know...
Dutch is different.
Oh, yes.
Dutch is certainly different.
He treats me fair.
Most of you do.
And for a fellow with a black father and an Indian mother, that ain't normally the case.
Well...
We need you now.
Or never.
Good.
And how long have you been with these boys?
Why ain't you friends with them?
I don't know.
How long have you run off?
Me?
Oh, 20 years. Somethin' like that.
Since I was a boy.
20 years?
Yeah.
He taught me to read.
John, too.
Taught me a few other things, him and Jose.
Huh. I'm sure.
Dutch saved me.
Saved most of us.
That's why we need to stick by him through this.
He always sees us right.
How's that new horse?
He's all right.
He'll do for now.
I appreciate you lettin' me take Taima the other night.
She's a strong one.
It's been as hard on the horses as on the rest of us.
I don't know what Dutch would do if something happened to the Count.
Same with Bill and Brown Jack.
Jack, he's a drunk miserable bastard, but he loves that horse.
Huh. I hope they all make it.
I tried to ride the cow once.
Puck me faster than a bull. Won't take nobody but him.
Whoa. I'm gonna hitch tie him over here.
Grab some food back, boys!
Come on, let's get these over to Pearson.
Oh, and thank you for showing me how to use the bow properly.
I only showed you a little. Takes a lifetime of practice to master.
Well, well, well.
Just drop it down in here.
What a surprise.
I found a camp rat loitering around in the kitchen.
Is that any way to greet an old friend? I feel like we haven't spoken for days.
I do my utmost to avoid you.
He loves me, really. It's his sad way of showing affection.
No, it isn't. Now shoot, get lost.
Well, see you gents later.
See, you got on just fine.
Charles is a wonder.
Have a drink, boys. You earned it.
Jesus, what is that?
Navy rum, sir.
It's the only thing.
The only thing?
Ha, ha, ha.
Keeps you sane, it does.
Yeah, seems to have done a treat on you.
You go rest that hand, Charles.
I'll be fine in a few days.
Mind helping me with the skinning, Mr. Morgan?
It's easier if we do it together.
Go get to skin you?
You're always one with the jokes, aren't you?
Come on.
This really isn't a job for a man with a burnt hand.
I'll see you both later.
You skim that one that you dumped on the floor there.
So you didn't pick that one.
Good American, detalbecause l like you so much.
Doctor K Industry president.
We'll try.
Yes, like March.
Not bad rewarding.
Arg, Mr. Morgan.
Shoo, my ass.
You never said you the leader of all the big men here in teachers' Sundays.
Thanks, which sang that tune?
Follow Billy Sweetbrain?
He had to hang his、
Prime Theosophas Island's name back to mypa's own nightmare language.
You're always gitu.
My name is Frank, very well-known.
And I think you'll never be...
Sir, bring it to me.
Sure.
Thank you, Mr. Morgan.
Heck, Arthur Morgan's first decent bit of hunting after all these years.
Yeah.
Well, we're on the run now. Everyone's gotta do their bit to survive.
Just make a good stew. Folk need it.
It's been a tough few days.
They say cruel histoire can come crumbling down the
lawn...
Keep Prepare
Up